hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we are going to discuss the top 10
AI tools for business in 2023 but before
we begin if you haven't already then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell to get
notified and also if you are an aspiring
artificial intelligence engineer looking
for online training and certifications
from the prestigious universities and
collaborating with leading experts to
have the most robust Foundation skills
knowledge and what it takes to be the
best then search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in artificial
intelligence from third University in
collaboration with IBM and simply learns
artificial intelligence and machine
learning boot camp from Caltech
University should be your right choice
for more details use the links in the
description box below with that in mind
let's get started with the first one
that is click up click up is an AI
powered assistant that is integrated to
the click up productivity platform it
can help you with a variety of tasks
including generating text translating
languages answering questions
brainstorming ideas summarizing
documents and much more when it comes to
generating text click up AI can generate
text for a wide variety of purposes such
as writing blog posts creating marketing
copy or summarizing documents and when
it comes to translating languages click
up AI can translate text between a
variety of languages moving to answering
questions click up AI can answer your
questions about a variety of topics such
as project management productivity or
business and next we have brainstorming
ideas click up AI can help you
brainstorm ideas for projects products
and marketing campaigns and lastly
summarizing documentations click up AI
can summarize documents into account
size and easy to understand format click
up AI is still under development but it
is already a powerful tool that can help
you save time and improve your
productivity here are some key features
of click up it is accessible via web
desktop and mobile apps 100 plus
role-based AI tools with ready to made
prompts slash write command quickly to
brainstorm your ideas access the AI
command from the text Toolbar to edit
text summarize long form content with
click of a button it can integrate with
clicker productivity platform and can
help you with a wide variety of tasks
such as generating text translating
languages answering questions
brainstorming ideas and summarizing
documentations now moving ahead into the
secondary tool for today's discussion
which is about chat GPT chat GPT is an
AI powered language model developed by
open AI it is capable of generating
human-like text based on context and
past conversations it is still under
development but it has already been used
for a variety of purposes such as
chatting with humans generating text
translating languages answering
questions let's discuss each one of
these chatting with humans chat GPT can
hold conversations with humans a little
bit in a limited capacity it can answer
questions follow instructions and even
tell stories when it comes to generating
text chat GPT can generate text for a
wide variety of purposes such as writing
blog posts creating marketing copy or or
summarizing documents it can also
translate languages and answer all of
your questions some of the key features
of chat GPT are as follows it has a
clean and minimalistic UI which makes it
extremely easy to use it has natural
language processing it has previous
conversation details about an
interactive which is two-way dialogues
and then it supports 50 plus languages
that is spoken languages and it has a
vast knowledge of Base spanning multiple
Industries and also has vast knowledge
based subject areas now we will move
into the next tool for today's
discussion that is door e or doll E2 is
a text to image diffusion model created
by open AI it can generate realistic
images from text descriptions for
example you can give it a prompt like a
cat riding a unicycle on a rainbow which
will generate an image of exact date
dollar is still considered to be under
development but it has already been used
to create some amazing images it has the
potential to be used for a variety of
purposes such as creating art designing
products generating Market materials
educating people when it comes to
creating art Dolly 2 can be used to
create original artwork such as
paintings drawings and sculptures when
it comes to designing products Dolly 2
can be used to design new products such
as clothing furniture or toys when it
comes to generating marketing materials
Dolly 2 can be used to generate
marketing materials such as posters
flyers and advertisements and lastly
when it comes to educating people Dolly
2 can be used to create educational
materials such as illustrations and
diagrams some of the most important key
features of Dolly 2R it is very
intuitive interface that makes it easy
to use it can generate unique and high
quality images in seconds the native
editing tool lets you generate text
prompts for replacing different elements
in a picture and it has an out painting
feature that lets you expand the canvas
now let's proceed into the fourth tool
for today's discussion that is Breakup
rack breakup rack AI is an EI powered
app generator that allows you to create
web applications games and tools without
coding it uses chat GPT 4 natural
language processing technology to
convert text descriptions into fully
functional web apps with a responsive
user interface breakup rack offers a
free plan that allows users to create up
to 6 apps per month and paid plans that
start at 68 dollars per month here are
some key features of breakup rack it is
a time saving and cost effective AI tool
for hiring professional and experienced
developers the built-in functional
applications from scratch in minutes
just using text an intuitive drag and
drop editor can let you create
customized AI tool to suit your needs
and requirements you can export your app
in file formats such as HTML CSS and
JavaScript it has unlimited a free web
app hosting capabilities now we will be
proceeding into the next tool for
today's discussion which is Tom Tom is
an AI powered storytelling tool that
helps you create and share immersive
narratives quickly and easily it uses a
combination of machine learning and
natural language processing to generate
presentations outlines and stories with
text images and other media Tome AI is
easy to use just type a description of
your desired presentation or story into
a text box and tomb AI well generated
for you you can then customize the
content and style for your liking
AI is a powerful tool that can be used
for a variety of purposes including
creating presentations for your work or
school writing posts or articles
developing marketing materials pitching
ideas to investors sharing personal
stories and much more
2 a i is still under development but it
is already a valuable tool for anyone
who wants to create and share their
ideas in a more engaging way some of the
key features of Dom AI are as follows it
can create a complete presentation with
text prompt only adds specific slides
pages to a presentation with natural
language prompts converts an upload a
document into a presentation with a
click of a button it can integrate with
a dolly tool to produce unique AI images
for your presentation embedded live
Pages for any website or external apps
and lastly it has sharing and commenting
features for collaborating with your
team now proceeding into the next tool
which is second brain second brain AI is
an AI powered writing companion that
helps you to write better articles
emails tweets messages and much more it
uses the DaVinci 003 text model from
open AI to generate a text and rephrase
existing text it also of first text
generation based on a prompt and
creating custom AI tasks second AI is
still under development but it has a
wide potential to be a powerful tool for
anyone who wants to improve their
writing skills here are some key
features of second brain it can be
helpful to training your new chatbot and
embedding it on your site page the
chatbot can be trained with data from 90
different languages it quickly and
accurately responds to your customer
queries you can also create multiple
Bots depending on your paid plan and
lastly it is great for entrepreneurs if
you are looking for a way to improve
your writing skills second brand AI is a
great option to consider it is easy to
use and affordable and it has potential
to help you write better articles email
and other content now let us proceed
into the next tool that is Jasper AI
Jasper AI is an AI writing assistant
that helps you create high quality
content quickly and easily it uses a
variety of AI models to generate text
translate languages write different
kinds of creative content and answer
your queries in an informative way
JavaScript AI is a powerful tool that
can be used for a variety of purposes
including writing blog posts and
articles creating marketing copies
translating languages answering customer
questions generating creative content
such as poems code scripts musical
pieces emails letters Etc some of the
key features of Jasper air it has 50
plus templates to speed up the content
creation process it can generate content
in 30 plus languages it lets you
repurpose content for multiple platforms
it has built-in collaboration tools for
working with your team it can fine-tune
content output to match your brand Stone
and style and lastly it can integrate
with grammarly copy space and Surfer SEO
Jasper AI is still under development but
it has already been used for businesses
of all time sizes to improve their
content marketing customer service and
much more if you are looking for a way
to improve your content creation Jasper
AI is a great option to consider it is
easy to use and affordable and it has
the potential to help you create better
content that will engage your audience
and help you achieve your business goals
next is plus AI plus AI is an AI tool
that helps businesses automate their
reporting and analytics it uses a wide
variety of AI models to extract insights
from data generate reports and create
dashboards plus AI is a powerful tool
that can be used for a variety of
purposes including automating reporting
and analytics tasks extracting insights
from data generating reports and
dashboards improving decision making
reducing costs the key features of plus
air as follows it is part by the latest
in generative AI it has integration
between Google slice and PowerPoint
which is seamless it can create a
presentation that needs only minor
editing it has the ability to rewrite
content on slides which is a quickest
Game Changer plus AI is still under
development but it has already been used
by businesses of all sizes to improve
their reporting and analytics
capabilities now let's proceed into the
ninth one which is about fireflies
fireflies is an air powered note maker
that can transcribe summarize and
analyze meetings it uses a combination
of machine learning and natural language
processing to automatically capture and
transcribe your meetings and then
generate summaries and insights that you
can use to stay on top of your work here
are some things that you can do with
fireflies AI stay on top of your work by
automatically transcribing and
summarizing your meetings get insights
into your team's discussions by
analyzing meeting transcripts share
meeting transcripts and insights with
your team members use meeting
transcripts to create presentations or
record hours and some of the key
features of fireflies are as follows it
can record and transcribe calls
instantly it has Chrome extension to
capture all your meetings it has simple
to use search that allows you to review
your calls and easy to use meeting board
to invite Firefly pods to a meeting
transcribe existing audio files
instantly inside the dashboard of a
native integration to dialers zapier and
other apis and lastly it eliminates the
task of note taking if you're looking
for AI tool that can help you improve
your productivity fireflies AI is a
great option to consider it is easy to
use and affordable and it has the
potential to save time and stay on top
of your work now the last tool for
today's discussion which is speechify
speechify is an AI powered text to
speech DTS tool that helps you read and
listen to text more efficiently it can
read aloud any text you provide
including PDFs articles websites and
social media posts speechify also offers
a variety of features to customize your
listening experience such as adjusting
the rating speed voice and background
noise some of the key features of
speechify are it has web-based with
chrome and Safari extensions more than
15 languages are supported by speechify
it has over 30 voices to select from and
it can scan and convert printed text to
speech speechify is an excellent tool
for anyone who wants to improve their
reading comprehension Focus or
productivity it can also be helpful for
people with dyslexia ADHD or other
learning disabilities I hope this helps
and with that we have reached to the end
of this session on the top 10 AI tools
for businesses in 2023. before we end
our session let's hear from our Learners
about their success story after
graduating from the postgraduate program
in AIML from Purdue University offered
by simply learn hey I'm hey I'm Sharia
Jaleel I live in Ontario Canada I have
been in I.T sector for the past 20 years
I recently took the professional
certificate program in artificial
intelligence and machine learning the
course has changed the way I look at
things and helped me back some amazing
freelance projects I started my career
in 1999 and over the years I have worked
with many companies my last tenor was
with IBM Canada my aim was to restart my
carrier and learn something that would
help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome the quality of
interaction within the course was simply
amazing the course faculty was also very
experienced and knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects also I
am planning to start an AI based startup
with my friend where I feel that the
learning from the course to be very
helpful I am really delighted and happy
in my free time I try to create
meaningful content on YouTube and I talk
about new technologies and what kind of
courses professionals should be taking
along with many other topic I definitely
recommend this course to everyone after
all when it comes to new skills to
advance your career there should be no
compromise you should always learn from
the band and with that we have finished
the session should you have any
questions do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will get back to you at the earliest
until next time thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from Simply
learn thank you
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign